A records map names to IP addresses as we
have seen. We have also seen what's called an NS
or a namesever record which maps a domain name
to the authoritative nameserver for that domain. So we saw
a bunch of NS records in the form of
referrals, whereby, if we ask the route for a mapping
of GaTech.edu to an IP address, it doesn't specifically know
the answer, but it can issue a nameserver reply or
an NS record referring the resolver to a
different nameserver that could be responsible for that
part of the domain name space. This allows
the domain name system to be implemented as
a hierarchy. Another important DNS record type is
an MX record, which shows the mail server
for a particular domain. Occasionally, one name actually
is just an alias for another name. For example,
www.gatech.edu actually has a slightly different real name. The
CNAME is basically a pointer from an alias to
another domain name that needs to be looked up.
The PT R is another record that we'll look at,
and this maps IP addresses to domain names. For
example if you wanted to know the name for
a particular IP address, you need to issue a
PT R query. This is sometimes called a reverse lookup.
Finally, a AAAA record maps a domain name to an IPV6 address. Let's take a look
at a couple of different examples of domain
name lookups using a command line utility called dig.